في الانتخابات التركيه ينظر الى كلش دار
جلو على انه فرس رهان في تلك الانتخابات
طبعا بحسب صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه لاول
مره منذ 20 عاما يواجه اردوغان باحتمال
الخساره حتى في معقله القديم طرابزون من
المتوقع ان يتراجع الدعم الذي كان يتحصل
عليه اردوغان عاده رغم انه لازال يحظى
بدعم ضخم بين قواعده الانتخابيه حيث ينظر
اليه كرجل دوله لكن شعبيه اردوغان تاثرت
بعوامل عده من بينها نهجه الاقتصادي فضلا
عن تعامل حكومته مع الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب البلاد في فبراير الماضيه ناهيك طبعا
عن شعور متنامن بان اردوغان بدا يفقد
بريقه لفتت الصحيفه الى ان ارتفاع تكاليف
المعيشه بات يغطي على كل شيء حيث سجلت
معدلات التضخم ارتفاعا بلاغه نسبته 85%
تمت عنصر اخر مؤثر في هذا السباق
الانتخابي هو ان حوالي خمس الناخبين
الاتراك هم دون سن ال 25 عام ولم يسبق
لنحو نصف هذا العدد التصويت من قبل فيما
تشير استطلاعات الراي الى ان نسبه كبيره
من هؤلاء الناخبين الجدد تعارض نظام الحكم
الذي ينتهجه اردوغان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات